[Musique]
grâce à sa voix claire et puissante
la soprano lyne fortin jouit d'une
réputation internationale comme la
plupart des artistes ces contrats des
prochains mois ont été annulés et s'est
donc tourné vers un nouveau public plus
petit et plus poilu oui mais codepeer
ronronne c'est sûr il y applaudit ce pas
parce qu'ils sont pas capables déjà
propriétaire de cinq chats elle est
connue dans son voisinage comme une
passionnée de félins
récemment elle a eu droit à toute une
surprise sur le pod saphores jour la
porte et joué loin de carton très
ordinaire et dessus un message qui dit
avec vous ça va bien aller à l'intérieur
de la boîte cinq chatons 4 caramel et un
noir impossible pour elle de garder des
chats dans sa maison s'est donc tourné
vers les réseaux sociaux et prix des
films j'ai mis ça sur facebook et ça n'a
pas été long j'ai eu plein de demandes
j'ai plein de gens qui m'ont écrit pour
me dire j'aimerais savoir un petit minou
j'ai fait des interviews pour voir qui
est ce qui était le plusieurs félins qui
est ce qui était plus en mesure de
s'occuper des bébés c'est pas jojo ben
c'est plate l'aco vide
je m'ennuie fait que j'aimerais savoir
un show ben c'est pas la copine ça va
passer le chat il va pas passer lui du
côté de la spéciale on confirme faire
face actuellement à une situation
inhabituelle avec moisson montréal on
est allé porter plaine nourriture plein
vite hier donc les gens qui étaient
contraints d'abandonner pour des raisons
financières maintenant ils ont accès par
les réseaux des banques alimentaires à
de la nourriture pour animaux
on a aussi encouragé d'espoir ya créé
des groupes sur facebook et ailleurs où
les gens qui veulent abandonner les gens
qui veulent adopter peuvent être mis en
contact sans passer par les murs de la
spéciale et on a toute une équipe le qui
vont aider les gens téléphonent en leur
donnant des conseils parfois les jambes
ont besoin de l'abandonner parce que
c'est des crèmes de comportement et
peut-être avec des petits conseils au
téléphone ça ils redoutent que la
situation empire à la proche de la
saison des déménagements qui
généralement la période où il est le
plus d'abandons il me dit du monde
les chatons de lyne fortin pourront
continuer à profiter de récitals privé
quelques semaines encore
elle attend le déconfinement et qu'ils
viennent un peu avant de séparer la
fratrie crois bien que je vais en garder
un parce que j'ai pas de tir où
alexandre charte ing canada montréal
ronde bonne et des petits bateaux
vous